make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
so x-force is the best thing coming out
of Marvel Comics right now because this
story is amazing dude god I love exports
it's absolutely amazing okay so an
x-force number one we're playing
catch-up right like those are guys who
are following the the x-men playlist
you're gonna kind of see like a big
content dump over the course of this
week kind of updating everything and
making sure that it's all in order for
the accident playlist I'm doing the
reason why I'm doing everything issue by
issue is to do with all in chronological
order right so that's why we kind of
have to play catch-up every once in a
while in case we missed something
especially we take a break for a week so
in the first issue of the first video
that we did we basically had kinda like
this big moment where Charles Xavier was
killed right in Charles Xavier was
killed by these various forces who
managed to infiltrate the island of Ko
Ko and now under normal circumstances
humans can't just walk into Krakauer
right I mean I guess they kind of can
they can drop in from the air but the
reason why a lot of the initial attack
was dismissed is because while you've
had sage who's a mutant whose brain
basically works like a computer storing
information different things like that
because of the fact that sage had
initially dismissed it because the
initial indication was that it was
basically Domino who was showing up what
we ended up finding out is that Domino
skin had basically been grafted onto
these various individuals who in turn
infiltrated kokoa
and then killed like 33 meets right one
of whom was Charles Xavier
now of course responding in the
aftermath of it all with the shooting
going on all that kind of stuff the
x-men really nullified the entire
conflict pretty fast I mean of course 33
beings were killed it was really more of
a surprise attack but with Charles
Xavier being one of them what this does
is it basically picks up with Magneto
and it's one of the coolest moments
right because magneto really kind of
looks at this this is why I love
benjamin percy writing so much but i
needa looked at this and says if only I
had been there I could have stopped the
bullet if only you've been made of metal
then you know I could have put you back
together if only if only and that's one
of the coolest things about this right
because there was a time when the death
of Charles Xavier well I would I would
never go as far as to say magneto would
never care that magneto totally wouldn't
show and wouldn't have shown the same
kind of remorse right he would have
busily got on a warpath and attack
everybody you know because of the fact
that Charles Xavier was this was one of
really as closest friend and that's an
important thing to understand when it
comes to the relationship between
Charles Xavier and Magneto that yes
they've been enemies yes they fought
each other constantly but there's a kind
of respect that runs there among the two
of them right the bond they share is is
pretty intense and so if somebody killed
the other then to be
held a pen and that's really the the
issue with Magneto because he kind of
has to hold back right the initial
desire of magneto is to make the world
suffer right like that's the initial
desire of magneto is to make the world
suffer here but the response is we can't
do that instead we have to continue the
charter of Charles Xavier and that
speaks mountains to the evolutionary
change of Magneto's character insofar as
again there was a time when he would
have said who cares what Charles Xavier
wanted everyone's got to die you know
but now it's the dream of Charles Xavier
was to basically turn Toccoa into a
place of peace for mutant kind and he
would not have wanted us to wage war on
the world in response to his death
that's a huge thing for magneto to
really sort of take on and to adopt here
and so the results of this is that you
have this conversation that goes on
between Magneto and Jean Grey and
basically you know Magneto's idea is you
have to find a way to resurrect you have
to bring him back but should it fail and
of course it's kind of this going back
and forth it won't fail it'll succeed
that kind of a thing now it's easy to
look at this indecision to know that
Charles Xavier is gonna be resurrected
right to know he's gonna come back it's
easy to look at that and to say his
death was all for naught but this is the
beauty of Dawn of X as it's being ran by
Jonathan Hickman and being written by
everybody else
Jonathan Hickman's perception of death
in comics is that often times it was
used as like shock value right like oh
my god this character died can you
believe it everybody gonna buy this
comics you could see you know that's
really kind of how had been treated in
the years that really came after the
death of Superman
and so Hickman's stance was if that's
the case if people are used to
characters dying and coming back then
let's keep that trend going but make the
death serve a purpose right don't use it
it's like a shock value don't use it as
like some kind of throwaway plot device
use it to serve a bigger purpose here
and that's the reason why Charles ezb
you're dying is significant is because
it's not the death of Xavier so like oh
my god Xavier dog you know I mean you'll
see a lot of like clickbait articles
from from news companies and things like
that who are like this blank x-man died
you know or something like that that's
really them kind of holding on to the
way things used to be as opposed to
changing with the modern times the
reality of this is it's like Charles
Xavier dying is designed to serve the
narrative of the story to serve the
purpose right so Xavier dying is no
different then if like you know the
x-men had lost a battle or something
like that
it's designed to keep the story going
and that's why I think it's cool here
because what you end up getting is
basically Jean Grey and Hank McCoy
travelling over to where cerebro is now
this was kind of a big thing is because
what Xavier had done is he had basically
taken cerebro which historically had
been
as a means to basically monitor in
discover various mutants around the
world he had taken it and used it as
essentially a computerized backup that
what he had done is is cerebro is
constantly backing up the various
memories of all the x-men who were there
and so when Domino was believed to have
been killed the last memory she
experienced would have been backed up to
cerebro but not only that xavier z'
final moments before he died would have
been backed up to cerebro so what this
means is they can resurrect xavier and
he comes back just like he was before he
died it's a pretty genius maneuver and
it's a pretty genius thing because the
story continues on it's kind of a
question of can this actually be
successful can this actually work now
this is where things really begin to get
interesting is because what you do is
you pick up with sage and you pick up
with a few of the individuals who have
basically been captured by the x-men
albeit they were dead at the time but
one of them is still alive and so
initially wolverine wants to slaughter
this guy right and this is where
wolverine is written incredibly well
right because Wolverines pissed like
he's angry right about the fact that
Xavier died but more so than that the
fact that like humans would have such
hubris as to invade Ricola and launch an
attack when no attack was instigated by
the mutant population right it was one
of those we just want a place where we
can be we could be alone do our own
thing and be fine and then in turn like
humanity attacked them anyway and so
initially Wolverine wants to kill this
guy but instead he kind of backs off and
he says get Jean Grey in here have her
scan this guy's mind before he dies
right because he's on his way to die
find out who brought him here how all
this stuff works whatever the case is
and then when they ask what were you
telling Wolverine gives us very simple
answer I'm going hunting and that's what
I love about Wolverine right because
when he's written well and this is
that's the struggle of Marvel Comics for
the struggle of Marvel Comics is to
write Wolverine in a compelling way when
he's written well all do Katie bar the
door do his stories aren't amazing like
they're fantastic it's crazy when
Wolverine is written well he's one of
the most interesting characters in
Marvel Comics when he's written poorly
then you get most of the stories that
he's been ahead as well that's the thing
here because what is up happening is
with all the information that had been
basically dumped to him by Jean Grey he
ends up travelling to Seoul South Korea
and when he gets there of course he's
doing his best to kind of break through
and figure out how these guys got on the
plane and where they came from or at
least you know how to sort of backtrack
their their their information and so on
but for the most part it doesn't work
right because Wolverine is not tech
savvy but then he's met by the arrival
of went inquire now let me tell you
something man but
mimics fish huh you putting fire yeah I
love pretty quiet Quinton choir is a
ridiculously powerful character right
he's an omega-level telepath this kid is
not to be trifled with but more so than
that you know what makes putting choir
so good dude he just doesn't care he's
just like so there's my way of doing
things and then there's the wrong way
the kid single-handedly led a revolt
against the entire team even put like
the entirety of like the Charles Xavier
school dude was one of the coolest
things ever there's this amazing moment
when he's what was it he's coming down
the stairs and wolverine tries to stop
him and he just like totally screws up
Wolverines mind and sends him through
like this insane maze in his own head
and Wolverines just like sitting there
totally incapacitated awesome amazing I
love the revolt of Clinton choir but
Quinten choir was very similar to
Magneto insofar as he believed that
mutants were superior to humans right
like mutants are better than humans and
we should rule accordingly right he very
much followed in Magneto's footsteps in
terms of like classic magneto wanting to
basically dominate humanity and then
turn mutants into like the superior
rulers of Earth and so it was kind of a
funny thing because what he basically
says here is like you're incompetent
when it comes to computers Wolverine so
basically everything you were trying to
do I've already done like I've traced
everything back I know exactly where
these guys came from and I also made a
credit card in your name and then ran up
the bill why because Quinn inquires kind
of a dick and it's funny and so what you
end up getting here is basically them
you know traveling to a location that's
just outside of Seoul which is basically
it looks like a giant place where
there's like newspapers being printed in
different things like that you know some
kind of giant printing location when
they get in there what they end up
finding out is everything but newspapers
is being printed here what's happening
is some organization out there it's
basically manufacturing assassins now
they're not manufacturing assassins
insofar as brainwashing humans what
they're doing or at least what it
appears they're doing is engineering
beings so they can serve as the perfect
assassins biologically engineered to
kill a mutants and so it's kind of a
kind of a nut situation because what you
end up getting is is basically like
quinton choir in wolverine in this
building and suddenly these biologically
engineered humans start attacking now
this really kind of draws out a couple
different conclusions right we can say
that they were in effect activated by
some third party or if that third party
is unaware they activate based on the
presence of mutants meaning they
basically had the ability to home in on
those individuals who have mutant
and those who don't that's really more
of a principle of Nimrod right Nimrod
was of course the ultimate Sentinel who
could actually detect a mutinous power
and a mutants weakness and then
capitalize on that weakness right
whether it was a phobia or whatever the
case happened to be he could use that
witness against them and then dominate
them and ultimately destroy them and
that's one of the reasons why Nimrod was
so capable as like the ultimate Sentinel
machine the other thing here is there
are basically mutant power dampeners in
this building meaning the powers of quit
inquire don't work now this also means
the powers of Wolverine don't work
insofar as his healing factor so if
Wolverines start sustaining injuries
until he leaves the presence of this of
this mutant dampening field his powers
won't work and that's kind of an
important thing to keep in mind and it's
actually a little bit of a big
revelation here right like putting
Wolverine in the place is actually one
of the cool little ways to kill
Wolverine so long as he stays in the
location whether it were his mutant
powers are damaged now of course that's
basically what the Muramasa blade us it
nullifies the power of the healing
factor of will reign entirely but it's
one of these cool little segments it's
kind of thrown in there that's sort of a
throwaway instance where like you could
kill Wolverine it's a cool little thing
so what will rain does is he basically
draws a conclusion and he tells quit
inquire if there's mutant dampening here
that it means that what they're trying
to do is hide someone they're trying to
hide like a mutant here and keep them
from using their powers and if that's
the case you have to find who that
mutant is most likely they're hiding
Domino here and of course when quit
inquire turns a corner he finds Domino
all basically sitting in this stasis
tank with half her skin missing which is
pretty screwed up oh that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to
when in if you are new here to come this
explained make sure you guys to the sub
button to be come forward with Rob port
if you guys want to see my uncensored in
vs. videos head over to patreon comments
explained and if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like that I
will catch you guys later peace I want
to give a shout out to Jason see Austin
s Jason s Austin H Phillip and Austin B
we have a lot of Austin's and our
patreon as well as G gnosis 916 de
gnosis didn't give us the first and last
name so we kind of had to roll with it I
didn't mention your last names after you
guys didn't want me to throw them out
there but I want to say thank you to you
all by the way your rob4 rings should be
on their way for our honor guard members
of the Rob core for these special
patrons your custom Rob core rings
should be on their way they're being
shipped to me after
I will have them shipped to you stay
tuned keep your eye on patreon in your
messages and you will hear about them
coming to you thank you
[Music]